the first Akiko started the
investigative elevation partners now
speaking out against the dangers of
social media Robert I'm Robert Roger
McNamee Roger great to see you I I see
you all over TV you're not running for
president are you not yet no but you are
sounding an alarm we have that in common
we have been talking about the same
thing the dangers of Facebook and the
phone the little phone and what's that
done to us and let's just start with the
term brain hacking because if you just
have to know one term and what it is and
why people like us are screaming about
this I would say it's encapsulated in
that term you explain it so my partner
Tristan Harris who was a guest of yours
yes here coined the term because what he
discovered was that essentially the
things media companies have done forever
they try to get your attention and get
you to pay attention to what they're
doing to sell products through
advertising when they applied that on a
smartphone it changed everything
suddenly had the ability to predict
people and if you had them addicted you
could change what they think you could
implant idea addicted to what
essentially whatever they likes right
well you know a feeling of oh they liked
my lunch yes that you can certainly do
that but it gets much worse than that no
actually what happens is they create
these things called filter bubbles in
the areas they put you in groups they
find out what you like and they appeal
to your fear they appeal to your anger
why because when you're angry or fearful
you are more engaged and the ads are
something you pay more attention to you
do more stuff you see more ads they can
generate more revenue when you're in
that position what they do is they
courage you to join these groups of
people who are just like you some of
whom are Russian BOTS some of whom are
you know other kinds of things that are
not real and when you're in that place
you think everyone agrees so what I
drive to work I see people in the
crosswalk looking at their phone yeah or
on the sidewalk what are they looking at
but what are they looking at even in the
crosswalk the way I think about it is
this way it's a beautiful day and
there's people and things to see
worse than that bill what happens if I'm
there they're celebrities right by them
they're looking at you they don't
understand what are they look because I
don't know what I would be looking at in
that situation let me introduce you have
a smart phone yes okay so when you wake
up in the morning how many minutes go by
between when you wake up and the first
time you check the phone Oh
half-hour okay so that's way more than
normal
I'll bet half the people in this
audience check their phones there's two
minutes thereof I know that's partly a
generational thing I get so much [ __ ]
when I when I criticize social media the
kids don't like it when Daddy shits on
their toys no but II like it better when
you clean it up okay all right but but
I'm doing it for them I've seen the
statistics it's making them sadder dude
when we were young we didn't listen to
our parents either okay so I don't think
that's the right tactic yes it makes you
sad or okay I'm not really a daddy it
was just a metaphor yeah
I'm not either so we're perfectly
qualified okay but I have seen this that
this is not making people feel better
about themselves it's much worse than
that with little kids this notion of the
fear of missing out these products like
Instagram and like snapchat which tell
you friends are together someplace and
you're not there right and that is
causing little kids not only to feel
left out there it's a form of bullying
and eventually some of them actually go
so far as to kill themselves right
you've seen a big rise in teen suicide
so the kid you know we work with a group
called Common Sense Media because
they're focused on how to protect
children from the dangers of products
like Facebook and Google and it's a hard
problem to solve
it's that's why we're trying to get
people to talk about we don't we don't
have all the answers today but we do
know is the problem it's not only here
the problem happened before we even knew
it it was a little bit like food in the
50s when they gave you all this
convenience everything's really
convenient easy and fun then you find
out later it's full of sugar salt and
fat well think about this technology as
being full of sugar salt and fat and
it's got an addictive thing like
cigarettes so that's a tough combination
and I think the depression factor is
also big is huge it's it's a little like
not getting sunshine you know in
Scandinavia the suicide rates are big in
the winter because they've one hour of
Sun a day and it's like if you have no
humor
in contact I think it's very similar if
you're always on a screen well it build
the issue is here it's the problem is
not social networking per se the problem
is the advertising business models
because what we've discovered is the
first 10 15 minutes of usage people
really are feeling better they love to
know what their family's doing but if
you stay on it long enough it keeps
throwing things at you designed to make
you either afraid or angry and then go
okay but the big news last week was that
Zuckerberg says he's changing the
Facebook model and it's gonna have less
public content less stuff from news
organizations and corporations and
businesses is this real is it going to
change anything total nonsense although
not the simple way of looking at is his
prescription for getting well on
Facebook is to do more of the exact
thing that makes you less well and it's
it's worse than that because if he had
done that change in 2015 it would have
had the effect of magnifying the Russian
interference in our election right well
and that's the one sentence I wish the
people who argue with me about this
would understand Russia used Facebook to
elect Donald Trump obviously that wasn't
the only factor but that is a true
statement is it not Russia used Facebook
to elect Donald Trump and it started
earlier than you think what they really
did is they got him because people get
their news from Facebook which is itself
scary there are two things that people
don't realize that a news source Russia
did not hack Facebook they used it
exactly as it was intended and the
second thing is that the Russian
technique was four years ahead of time
they were promoting these highly
corrosive topics things that would would
cause more you know more anger in the
country and divided the country and they
did this for three or four years and
Trump comes along with all the same
issues he's focused on immigration he's
focused on guns he's focused on white
supremacy those are the very things they
had been promoting and so he inherited
all of that investment and he got
himself nominated and then once he was
knotted they did more stuff and then
obviously chaos took place and the
problem we have is that with all the
focus on trying to prove that there was
collusion and all that stuff we've
forgotten it hey wait a minute Facebook
is still there people are going to use
Facebook in 2018 and 2020 so the same
way
now the Russians have shown you how to
do it so literally bazillion support if
you were a tutor or mentor to Mark
Zuckerberg
I mean you advised him like he was gonna
sell it right when it was worth way less
he never wanted to sell the people
around him wanted to sell it it happened
look I was one of his mentor's for a
period of time I helped him on a couple
of really important things like not
losing the company bringing in Sheryl
Sandberg things that really did matter
and then my time was done that was 2010
I'm not really paying attention until
the beginning of the Democratic primary
and I start to see things that you can't
explain except somebody is messing with
Facebook and then I see things that
aren't election related that are just
the same way back to him so here's what
happened I reached out to them in
October of 2016 and I'd written an op-ed
and instead of publishing it it listed
seven different things that I thought
were systemic problems with Facebook
that could only be fixed by them they
had to go in and change the way the
granny worked I sent it to him in to
Cheryl ten days before the election they
were really polite and really firm not
our problem
their basic notion was that so what
about now is he gonna do anything now I
mean he's worth seventy five billion
dollars what what is it with these guys
you know he wears the same shirt every
day you know these tech companies they
think they're better than regular
companies because they got a [ __ ] nap
room or something like that but really
they act just like an oil company when
you talk about the greed and the sexism
in every everything every other bed what
you can't call this guy and say come on
you were supposed to be different you
were you at your big make the new boss
same as the old boss what a strong when
you have a political promise to reach
out to people who disagree with you the
critics they've never done that they
weren't talking to me they aren't
talking to anybody they think they've
got it all figured out and the sad part
of this is I'm convinced there's a
better way to run Facebook they could be
more profitable more successful without
poisoning of the brains of their users
right now what they have is a profitable
what if he is only ordered sixty five
billion dollars then he's not gonna
listen to you okay I think I have to
come to a better idea because it's the
only way to get him to listen oh because
we need their help to fix the problem go
do it I'm gonna do my thank you very
much for
[Applause]